oh my dear brothers and sisters may
Allah bless you all this video inal I'll
be dealing with the lies and the and the
fabrication that some people are
spreading based upon a Zionist newspaper
and Subhan Allah what is very
interesting some people some Muslims the
same newspaper who accused Hamas and the
Palestinians to be that they killed the
babies and Slaughter Slaughter the
babies they rejected it and they say
they are liars so this a newspaper they
say they are liars anyway so my dear
brothers and sisters but Subhan Allah as
theab
say the enemy of my enemy is my beloved
one all right and Subhan Allah some
Muslims they have this man mentality of
claiming they love sh they call for but
when they deal with the they the Under
The Bu they become liberals and one of
them which is has a deep hatred well
rooted because he was a RAF and you know
the Sal is the love sahaba they defend
sahaba openly privately everywhere they
have no mercy when it comes to defending
the sahab they expose the Liars in
detail he has that deep hatred well root
rooted hatred against who praise sah
spread the virt of sahab there's no one
other
Thani after I have exposed his ignorance
that this individual is full of
ignorance he is arrogant deceiver and he
has no knowledge so after he kept speak
K I've exposed him I spoked him face to
face and he he couldn't bring one verse
or one Hadith while I was bringing verse
in a
Hadith and because of that he became
very uh hostile towards
me even you can analyze his speech his
tweets before my discussion with him and
after when I came to him I put him on
the spot he couldn't answer he was just
lying waffling so my dear brothers and
sisters we have written some points here
against gu the lies or what has been
mentioned in the article on the article
is newspaper zus newspaper on its
website there's a section the section is
for everyone to come and say whatever
they like even when you go check it
because Richard sue the newspaper that
is a lie what is being said in the
article all right so in the in that
section anyone can come and write is
basically the newspaper itself
Fabricators liars and they open free
forum for everyone to come and lie cuz
you know
as
the said the S are recruited soldiers so
of course who's coming to speak in the
section in the on the website except the
lies and the Fabricators like them so
they say it is not their
responsibility any whatever has been
said on this section that is not for it
does not belong to them basically did
you know that the writer of the
article has some strong relationship
with
uh when I say strong relationship
they've been he's been following him for
three years or more or less and they've
been having many discussions and he
comments he has a lot of comments on on
Facebook and uh guess what the the the
article writer uh he's from the same
city as Texas okay likewise the the the
writer the article writer has deleted
his face Facebook yesterday out of
nowhere he just deleted his Facebook so
there's many indication to indicate
there is a connection between the writer
and because if you read the article some
paragraphs the same way speaks Subhan
Allah this very interesting and by the
way the author we're going to put up
pictures when he's dressed like a Muslim
one dressed like a Jew suban Allah look
when they cannot refute us with
knowledge they have to lie and what is
very interesting something we have to
take on board did you know that the
article writer himself has praised we're
going to show you the proofs okay that's
praised
Mam and other guys and and James White a
Christian preacher and on on a different
uh uh websites speaking about Pakistan
and prais in Pakistan so it's very
interest it's very weird Subhan Allah
but alhamdulillah Allah said in the
Quran
they plan and Allah plans and Allah is
the best of the planners so Subhan Allah
Allah mentioned that he will give
Victory to his
servant these are liars Allah always
expose them they will get exposed and
also what we have to to understand my
dear brothers and sisters may Allah
bless you all
that he claimed that he became Sunni he
was a ra but he has no articles speaking
and exposing the ra Iran
regime but day and night speaking
against the Sunni countries even in the
article if you read between the lines I
I don't think you have to read between
the lines when he speaks against he say
he was a but his Ang Zionist and ask me
as a Sunni I'm a pro
Zionist from a lie there's many videos
you can go back check we make Dua
against zus we did in our M and zist
clearly say Allah destroy the Zionist
may Allah give Victory to our brothers
and sister in festine clearly and you
know what it's very interesting some
people who have a deep hatred against
sunah in the comment section they will
still call you Zionist and they are the
Zionist okay cuz what's happening now
and they have been exposed in Morocco
Algeria in Saudi there is some Zionist
who know Arabic language so what they
doing they're creating fitna between the
Algerian people and Moroccans and Saudis
and and between each other and the
Muslims and they speak Arabic and they
will accuse you to be Zionist Subhan
Allah so so what is like I mentioned why
has no articus against rather no longer
ago he praised who theis who are theis
who killed many innocent uh uh Muslims
in Yemen and they are still doing it go
ask the people of AD people of Yemen
generally speaking how do who are what
they call pretending they're going to
defend Gazza when they their Scholars
openly came out yes one of them openly
came out so we have nothing to do with
Philistine and let me tell you
something Iran when they wanted to help
uh Yemen they they give them destructive
powerful weapon to kill the yemenis
Sunni yemenis likewise when they wanted
to help Syria uh regime Syrian regime
they give them a powerful weapons to
kill the syrians all right sunnis
likewise for Iraq but when it comes to
have the Palestinians they give them
some toys it's like they they setting
them up they set them up likewise Allah
mention or you believe with the sinner
come to you with the news verify it let
alone the zus a liar and Subhan Allah so
like I said uh they say this newspaper
are liars like I said it's not even the
newspaper that said it for the sake of
argument let us say the person himself
he works for the newspaper directly but
the newspaper just they are liars
disbelievers look how expose you because
the Deep hatred you have that will allow
you to deal with based upon Justice a
person might say but you oppress people
too for the sake of argument if someone
oppress you are you not
oppressive shows you you opposing Shar
so it shows you that a person you are a
sheep if someone oppress you oppress
him so don't use argument because
alhamdulillah any person that we dealt
with I will challenge them to come out
and tell us we oppress them Quran sunah
and the way of the that's why they hate
us because they cannot refute us with
Quran andah so the first claim where is
funny my dear brothers and sisters in
the article they
say they
say Islamic scholar no no please next
time call
me you have to respect me more bro I
mean senior Scher is not I'm just being
sarcastic so I'm a Senor
caller so that's his claim I'm what call
it has advocated for peace with the
Jewish state of Israel you're liar Allah
curse you and break you back and break
the backs of the Zionist and Destroy
them how I call for a peace treaty who
am I to call liar what is doing the Shan
as his forefathers he I don't even I
think this guy
but for the s for the sake argument say
Yi Zionist then your forefathers they
did the same with the book of
Allah they hear speech of Allah then
they change it what about my speech so
what is he talking about here which is
taken
from the issue of in a time of
warrah like I said Quran not a motion
Quran Sunnah is above you is above
anyone's heads above my head and above
all the head the Quran is criteria if
you don't like it get out simple as that
Quran andah is the criteria with me all
all day long until we meet Allah inah
so Allah
said
so this is from Allah speech if there's
a situation of fear or peace instead of
spreading it speaking about it you
should refer it back to Allah's
messenger and go
check the scholars and the
leaders now in a time of necessity out
of necessity if the Muslims they think
you know it's out of necessity to do
peace treat treaty to have a peace
treaty okay that is allowed the school
has mentioned that all right now what is
my position my position firstly my
Palestinian Brothers if you're able to
kick them out kick them out the zist
because they are Invaders not every
Jewish person because Jewish people they
have a right to live there under the
Islamic under the Palestinian government
because that country belongs to
Palestinians so don't try to say
anti-semitic term that has been used to
stop people speak out and gu you oppress
against the people don't try to utilize
against gu me that country belong to
Palestinians you invade that country
you've been oppressing the Palestinians
for many many years and Allah exposed
you that you are a liars and deceivers
and a murderers and The Killers baby
killers you are the Zionist when you try
to accuse the other party so he's a liar
this goes back to if our necessity
Prophet Muhammad said did
it but goes back to whom goes back to
schols and the leaders mentioned that if
you have problem you have problem with
Allah he
lied bear in mind Imani to show you
these people have disease Al he was ask
about having peace treaty he said you
have peace treaty with them he was in
opinion there's not peace treaty with
them but how come you don't mention that
fwa because we expose your agenda so you
mention a f when im Al was breaking it
down again based upon what Quran Sunnah
many Muslims have noticed in a time of f
they become liberal like one of them I I
challenged him he become liberal and it
become like a uh he asking for people's
opinions when we know in a time of War
and Peace Allah mentioned what go Quran
and to the schols and the leaders not to
a group of people speak again to show
you this person there's a big question
mark on the top of his head especially
there's many indications to indicate
this person is his really Sunni or is
still rafidi hidden rafidi who wants to
destroy from within and we ask Allah to
deal with him so IM Al may Allah have
mercy upon him he was asked long time
ago over 25 years or something that what
is the the issue or the the the
situation of Palestine he said they
cannot fight back they should not be
leave staying under the oppression of
these oppressors he they call them uh
beloved ones oppressors tyrants he says
because he he's an opinion remember an
Alban's an opinion is Haram to live in a
non-muslim
countries is Haram even if you have a
money of your ticket to go to back home
leave the
country and he was he said the Muslim
should not be living under the
oppression of this Tyrant Zionist they
oppressing them they are uh humiliating
them he said if they can fight back let
them do it but if they cannot then they
have uh the example of the Prophet
Muhammad
and his companions but look this evil
man he tried to portray Al he said he
even
accept uh state of Israel you're liar we
don't know country called Israel by the
way in my country Algeria when I when I
came this country and I remember some Yi
and say yeah he told me I'm from Israel
I'm Israel where you know canot register
in my brain isra country Israel the only
thing can register in my in my heart is
the prophet isra country called Israel I
don't know it and no country callede so
the guy who tried to explain to me you
know this way Jordan this I said listen
is called Palestine you are Invaders and
you need to leave okay and with my
people who are fighting against you the
Palestinian people okay clearly so
you're a liar I mean I mentioned it
before even I mentioned to one uh
Palestinian brother I was speaking to
him on Tik Tok he said come to pH
I said how he said you know you have to
go through the isra airport I said no no
man I can't do that man I can't I said
he said yeah if you have British
passport you can use your British
passport I said no about British
passport because I cannot go there with
Algerian passport if I go there I go
back to Algeria prison we don't accept
this country we don't know country
called Israel okay I said to him even
with the British passport I'm not going
to go there because my heart does not
allow me I go see the this murderers
like controlling or I'm under them no
way there's other brothers some Muslims
they go they say because you want to
visit M AA that me personally I can't do
it no way inshallah may Allah prolong my
life upon his obedience and Allah free
that land Philistine and our Palestinian
Brothers they will control all of it
under the government I will go visit my
the in
so the
the and he was you and this we call for
peace peace with who with the Invaders
with the murderers with the rapist with
the killers with the satans never except
like I mention if they go to the
Palestinian leaders and the scholars and
the scholars are the Muslim leaders and
they think is the best time of necessity
is as Allah mentioned the Quran if you
have problem you have problem with the
Quran
also one of his claim I forgot his name
his name
zi or something they said they they
unquestioning obedience to governments
even those that are clearly pro Israel
such as UAE Jordan Egypt Morocco and
Sudan Etc means that are the obviously
policies that benefit Israel will not be
opposed but
supported Allah curse the Liars you are
a
liar first this countri are not pro
Israel okay I have to be just all right
I'm an Algerian Algeria we against we
don't have no relationship with Satan
okay alhamdulillah so some countries
they look at it like Jordan the brother
who was from Jordan he said to me the
reason they have that treaty with them
to allow food and other things come into
the country all right this goes back to
them okay but we have to we have to
speak with Justice Morocco is not pro
Israel okay they do business with them
if the leader is doing something Morocco
leader Algerian leader any Muslim leader
is doing something which oppos quannah
dealing with then I'm free from it I'm
free from it I will never support it and
by the way how I'm going to
support a country or except a country I
believe doesn't exist that doesn't make
any sense it's a paradox how I'm going
to never never support this Shan may
Allah destroy you zist and Aid our
brother in festine never this this
inside us alhamdulillah we never in let
let our brother and stin down we advise
them remind them alhamdulillah they
advise us remind us alhamdulillah so we
don't we don't not say you have to
listen and hear and obey the leaders
whatever they do no if they do something
oppos Quanah we reject it we're free
from it however Quran tell us if you
want to speak out and guess the leader
you go speak out and guess him face to
face not he is in Algeria I'm in Britain
but what I can do at least hate with my
heart which alhamdulillah my brothers
who are close to me they know so things
I see some countries
doing Allah guide them man may Allah
guide them well is alhamd we don't call
for Rebellion okay we don't call for
speaking about the mistakes of the
leaders openly we refute it without
mention the leader's name but
alhamdulillah I'm free from it I made a
video
about ibim okay I made video and I said
IB has nothing to do with Judaism and
Christianity I made go back two two
years back I made a video about it in
Arabic and English so my video are
approved and guess you I mean the the
guy who has connection withu maybe could
be your best friend never
know third claim shockingly it openly
promote the idea of removing all
Palestinians from the West Bank and Gaza
and theit
the authority and the power of modern
states of isra there's no State called
Israel Over the territories that are
considered Palestinian this is a another
claim our may Allah preserve him said
it's very strange he has written 16
article just in two weeks on the uh
newspaper doy so to make it seem he's
part of it he's been doing it for a long
time but he's been exposed two years ago
he was praised
it's very strange Subhan Allah anyway
I'm not going to repeat myself again the
alhamdulillah our schol
aldah we are against against you okay we
against you we free from you we refute
you we expose you okay now there are
some issues it goes back to the leaders
not us we say from our feelings you like
it or you don't like it Quran and Sunnah
and my brothers out there the Muslims if
you have a problem with that let's sit
down Quran and Sunnah cuz I know some of
you you are grave worshippers some of
you you live under in the western world
and you hate the Muslim countries and
the Western World the some of the
enemies in the Western World they are
utilizing you to promote violence and
destruction in the Muslim countries when
they use you like a dogs they give you
food and drink and they say keep barking
no problem as long you don't attack them
the like a dogs they say yeah but here
we are free we can talk they give us
like a dog what do I can bring a dog I
said look I give him food drink house
and he start baring everyone when start
barking at me or my children I stop
that's how the Western World some in the
Western World governments they are
utilizing you they allow you they give
you food everything they tell you back
at the Muslim countries promote violence
hatred as long you don't do it against
us what you do against us they kick you
out so alhamd I have to repeat again our
criteria
is the qurnah and the way of the and
I've challenged many people for many
years aldah everywhere I'm on the road
everywhere alhamdulillah you people
hiding behind cameras and and and fake
people face to face you praise us you
speak good of us then when you go online
behind the cameras and you start lying
and and slander us Alani they knew
albani he's one of the revivers and he
exposed them alhamdulillah that's why
they want to lie and get
in this article albani quannah albani he
was advising the Palestinians based upon
the Quran Sunnah but we don't like it
now like chilon they Chang the colors
they changed their colors Subhan Allah
anyway for the Zionist and people out
there Moses in your own book did he not
leave Egypt and his for and his
disciples that doesn't mean they were
happy with or they say should take over
because they have the power Allah ow
them to leave then Allah gave them the
same
land we made them the inheritance of the
land so some Muslims out there like I
repeat again fear Allah have noticed you
become liberal you become Democratic you
oppose the Quan read the story of the
prophets and Messengers so Al F based
upon the Quanah now do we have to Blind
for albani albani is not Prophet we take
and reject but now when you reject his
say okay say you're wrong here IM your
scholar we respect you no problem with
that based upon ref him no with your
liberal principles with the
principles let me repeat again Quran do
have the this our criteria then the F
claim this give me headache man this
thing this guy full of lies manism is a
strain of Islamic thought that is most
friendly
to you are our enemies and we are your
enemies make it clear to you you're a
Zionist even your even Jewish people
against you and they call you enemies
you are murderers liars deceivers
Killers San followers how we friend
never never doesn't mean some Muslim
leaders are having relationship or sa
no like I said if he going back to what
going to benefit the Muslim Muslims and
the Palestinians and our necessity based
upon quannah Quan is above my feeling is
above my head that's it but even even
having peace treaty with you doesn't
mean you are
friends because the when he had peace
treaty likewise when he had peace treaty
with the with the Crusades likewise when
he had the peace treat with the
Christians in andelo doesn't mean they
were friends
orah so stop lie in your liar so this Li
this I mean in so far it's so clear this
man is a liar he's a Shan RAF friend
of because please tell me why this guy
out of nowhere deleted his Facebook page
which Brothers can trace back they have
been having conversation back in
2018 and like I mentioned he praised him
so alhamdulillah this enough to to
expose the liars and to show that they
couldn't refute us with the Quran and
Sunnah they had to to lie and gu us
watch
this is is Channel 4 the British Channel
you want to see video that Arabs kill my
friends I have yeah of course they have
to defend themselves of course they
brother I'm not going to deny that they
have a right to kill you for defending
themselves I'm not going to deny that
but you come into my country so imagine
you come to I told four months ago
praising and defending Philistine saying
they have a right to fight you and
because you are the you are the Invaders
and and you're oppressors then you
li but like I said the Arab they say
enemy of my enemy is my beloved one and
this
tactic he become bankrupt in anyway he's
a j have hat against because he's
just hidden there's indication that this
man is a hidden who has a
deep and
because they Expos the of the and and
they and the way of the and this man has
been hidden refuted liberalism but you
can see many things he he act like a
liberal Subhan Allah and he has a
mission to he's on a mission to destroy
Muslim countries and this war in festine
by the way what's happening now they
want to
glorify okay and promote as a Savor
forah on the other hand that Sunni
countries Bel the Sunni countries ra
they will never be saviors of Islam
never historically speaking they're only
known to stop us in the back
so that they are fighting who are
killing is a big question there's other
indications by the
way we ask Allah to protect us and the
Muslims from the evil of the and the
Zionist and the enemies of Islam we ask
Allah to make us from those who follow
the Quran the Sunnah and with the S
inwardly and
outwardly